>>> TONIGHT, THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE KILLING OF A LONG-TIME
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER IN LAS
VEGAS IS RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT
A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT HE
HAD WRITTEN ABOUT.
POLICE CONFIRMING TO CNN THAT
THEY HAVE SERVED SEARCH WARRANTS
IN CONNECTION WITH THE DEATH OF
THE REPORTER, FOUND DEAD OUTSIDE
HIS HOME IN BROAD DAYLIGHT
SATURDAY MORNING.
OFFICERS SEEN TODAY OUTSIDE THE
HOME OF ROBERT TELLIS, WHO
DIDN'T RESPOND TO REPORTERS WHEN
HE RETURNED HOME LATER IN THE
DAY.
THE SEARCH TO HIS HOME MAY BE
CONNECTED TO GARMIN'S KILLING.
"OUTFRONT" NOW IS ART CAIN, WHO
WORKED CLOSELY WITH JEFF GERMEN.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I'M SORRY FOR THE SHOCKING LOSS
THAT YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE
EXPERIENCING.
UNIMAGINABLE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
POLICE HAVE RELEASED AN IMAGE OF
A VEHICLE THAT THEY SAY IS TIED
TO THE SUSPECT, A RED, MAROONISH
SUV.
OUR AFFILIATE CAPTURED FOOTAGE
OF A CAR BEING TOWED FROM
TELLIS' DRIVEWAY.
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED, WHAT MORE CAN YOU
TELL US ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, IT TOOK A TURN TODAY,
BECAUSE OVER THE WEEKEND, WE HAD
ASSUMED IT WAS A, YOU KNOW,
ROBBERY GONE BAD OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
AND YESTERDAY AFTERNOON, POLICE
RELEASED A PICTURE OF THIS
VEHICLE.
AND OUR REPORTERS STARTED TO SEE
THE IMAGES OF THIS VEHICLE THAT
LOOKS LIKE A VEHICLE JUST LIKE
IN TELLIS' DRIVEWAY.
SO THAT WAS REALLY CONCERNING
AND SURPRISING.
AND THEN THIS MORNING, THE
POLICE CAME DOWN AND ROPED OFF
THE AREA, STARTED SEARCHING HIS
HOUSE, AND TOOK THAT VEHICLE,
REGISTERED TO TELLIS' WIFE, THAT
LOOKED LIKE THE VEHICLE THEY
RELEASED EARLIER THAT DAY.
THAT'S ABOUT ALL WE KNOW RIGHT
NOW.
POLICE HAVEN'T DONE ANY KIND OF
PRESS CONFERENCES.
BUT CLEARLY, IT'S VERY
CONCERNING IF THERE'S SOME
INVOLVEMENT FROM TELLIS IN THIS.
>> IT'S SHOCKING.
RIGHT AT THIS POINT, WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE RELATIONSHIP IS,
BUT IT IS PRETTY SHOCKING WHAT
WE KNOW SO FAR.
OBVIOUSLY, TELLIS HASN'T BEEN
ARRESTED OR CHARGED AND POLICE
HAVEN'T SPOKEN OR CONNECTED HIM
TO THE INVESTIGATION.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT AFTER JEFF'S
REPORTING ON TELLIS, THERE WAS A
PUBLIC CLASH THAT HE REPORTED ON
TELLIS' OFFICE OVERSIGHT, AN
INAPPROPRIATE RELATIONSHIP HE
HAD WITH A STAFFER.
HE DENIED THAT, CALLING HIM A
BULLY.
JEFF, TELLIS LOST HIS
RE-ELECTION BID IN JUNE.
HE LOST IT AFTER THESE THINGS
CAME OUT.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT HOW
JEFF'S REPORTING WAS RECEIVED?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
UNUSUAL FOR SOMEONE WHO IS THE
FOCUS OR TARGET OF AN
INVESTIGATOR'S STORY THAT JEFF
OR I OR SOME OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM DO TO PUSH
BACK AND CLAIM THAT THEY'RE
BEING TREATED UNFAIRLY.
TELLIS GOT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
IN THE STORY.
TALKED TO JEFF.
HIS POINTS OF VIEW WERE
REPRESENTED.
AND THERE WASN'T ANY CORRECTIONS
OR ANYTHINGFACTUALLY WRONG, HE
JUST DIDN'T LIKE HE WAS BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SO I WOULDN'T CALL IT A CLASH.
I WOULD CALL IT THAT JEFF DIDN'T
RESPOND, OTHER THAN CONTINUING
HIS REPORTING.
TELLIS JUST LASHED OUT AT HIM.
>> CAN YOU JUST TELL ME A LITTLE
BIT -- IT'S A SHOCKING STORY,
WITH A FOCUS ON JOURNALISM AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT JEFF,
AS A PERSON, THAT YOU WORKED
WITH?
>> WELL, JEFF IS THE ULTIMATE
VEGAS REPORTER.
HE'S BEEN HERE 30 YEARS, COVERED
EVERYTHING FROM THE MOB TO THE
FIRE AT THE MGM GRAND, TO THE --
WE COVERED THE OCTOBER 1
SHOOTING TOGETHER.
WE'VE DONE SEVERAL
INVESTIGATIONS, INCLUDING OF THE
LBCBA, WHICH IS THE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY THAT CAME UP WITH THE --
WHAT HAPPENS HERE, STAYS HERE
SLOGAN FOR VEGAS, AND WE FOUND A
LOT OF WAYS TO END CORRUPTION
THERE.
SOME PEOPLE GOT INDICTED AFTER
THE SERIES OF STORIES WE RAN.
SO HE BASICALLY WAS, YOU KNOW,